the quality of an actor's work on screen
might be a matter of opinion most at the
time but there are some performances so
awful that all subjectivity goes out the
window
in the case of D seams the acting is so
over-the-top and bizarre that it's hard
not to laugh at them even years after
the fact talk about sucking just about
everyone involved in the adaptation of
Stephenie Meyer's vampire romance could
be accused of phoning it in
but Twilight MVP Kristen Stewart takes
top honors for worst performance in the
movies climactic scene it all starts
with a trio of nomadic vamps lurk around
looking for something to eat when they
stumble across the Cullen clan playing
Facebook while they're protected human
pet watches on a standoff in zoos and
almost ends peacefully for James catches
a whiff of Bella and gets the munchies
we brought it back the situation is
defused but not done James the track
advant buyer vows to hunker down and eat
her despite the Cullens best efforts the
hider he lures are away from the columns
and savagely snaps a leg spell is
sparkly vampire boyfriend
Edward arrives to save her from certain
death but James still manages to sink
his teeth into her arm the venom from
his flight starts to spread through her
veins right away which is when she
informed everyone in Maya's book the
pain is described as quote exquisite but
watching Stewart's grunting and
grimacing in the moment makes those tiny
teeth marks look anything but the nose
nose Richard Linklater's coming-of-age
classic Dazed and Confused gave us the
gift of many quotable Matthew
McConaughey moments you just got to keep
leathern man LR vrn but it's also
responsible for the unbearable nuisance
of Mitch Kramer the group of freshmen is
a categorical case study in social
awkwardness so there's some lack of
screen savvy to be expected from his
portrayal but in the scene where he's
trying to flirt with Sabrina outside the
Emporium its Full Tilt amateur-hour
instead of coming out with traditional
acting devices like
expressions bug reflection pure presence
active Wylie Wiggins relied on eight yes
eight cringe-worthy knows grass five
hair flicks we came here and one super
clumsy elbow nudge to coast through the
same link later eventually accepted
responsibility for letting this bad slip
through the editing cracks telling The
Daily Beast I just thought the nose grab
was kind of an awkward gesture under
director so it's on me that's the thing
people notice only if it's the third
time you watch it I just thought it was
that young awkward man kind of thing
maybe it was one or two too many when it
comes to removing a few of those nose
grabs maybe on a remastered cut of the
movie well Emily a large curler if you
did pass the turkey considering Julie is
a movie who's six percent wide and
tomatoes score is probably a little
generous there are a lot of forceful
aspects to choose from you know some
you're right it is that emphasized
enough that the stupidity of this thing
extends all the way up to the title
itself so it's a tall order to pick just
one scene as the worst of the worst
since Julie was such a turkey at the box
office though it makes sense to focus on
the scene that tried and failed
miserably to make Thanksgiving themed
cuisine a workable piece of sexy
dialogue in the movie Jennifer Lopez
plays a lesbian named Ricky who decides
to make Ben Affleck's hitman have boy
toy and inviting into a bad like so
turkey time
that's whenever I'm watching this movie
did this the jerky talk is an evergreen
highlight for both Ben and Jen's career
blooper reels even though they've tried
to put the picture into perspective
ever since yeah there are the worth more
than Gigli out there the empty box with
all due respect to Brad Pitt this
performative 7 is a classic case of an
acted completely missing the emotional
mark of an important movie moment
instead of delivering on what might have
been a powerful scene he made a bit of a
mockery of himself to be fair to Pitt he
was working with three industry giants
directed David Fincher and actors Kevin
Spacey and Morgan Freeman while he was
still something of a Hollywood newcomer
at the time but compared to everyone
else's delivery in the rap scene his
contribution is pretty inexcusable
in the grand finale of John Dos deadly
sins inspired Plan Kevin Spacey's killer
character leads the detective juror
after the desert to find a package
containing something Freeman's character
gets a gander at it first and his face
dutifully reflects the grim reality of
the situation we're led to believe it's
the head of mills pregnant wife Tracy
and innocent and lovely lady who has
nothing to do with any of this mess but
we never get to see the contents the
tension is staggering until Pitt's not
screaming his lines and jumping around
like a carnival clown so he was a Fogg
who was in the bar what's in the box
what's in a box
it's a scene ruin upon rewatching it
looking back you might be tempted to
believe it was secretly Pitt's talent
that was actually hidden in the box
those bloody wolves
if Keanu Reeves could really take a bill
and ted's style journey back in time we
hope he did lead consider returning to
the early 90s and undoing everything he
did in Bram Stoker's Dracula at the very
least he should retro actively hire
himself a proper dialect coach because
his British accent is so horrible that
it actually distracts viewers from
fixating on Gary Oldman's giant Blood
League which is quite a feat in one
scene in particular Reeves character
starts to realize that account is bad
news and delivers a recap for these
Transylvanian adventures
that's way funnier than its supposed to
be I've seen many strange things already
bloody wolves chasing me through some
blue inferno even director Francis Ford
Coppola who's practically president of
baqia know Reeves fan club had to admit
to Entertainment Weekly it was tough to
him to affect an English accent he tried
so hard that was the problem actually he
wanted to do it perfectly and in trying
to do it perfectly it came off as
stilted in other words I doubted
everything even my mind I was impotent
to fear the fumble 1999 presented two
major movie moments depicting sons
rejecting the stodgy old dad's wishes
for them to follow in their footsteps
and one of those things was not like the
other Jake Gyllenhaal's breakthrough
performance as Homer Hickman in October
sky features him standing up to the
status quo of going to the mineshaft
after school with his dad instead he
literally reaches for the sky as a
wannabe space cadet who builds Rockets
on the sly
it builds to a poignant moment a
father-son friction that totally
resonates the way it should
Coleman's your life it's not mine
[Music]
compare Zack to james van der beek
showdown with his own popped in varsity
blues which hit theaters a few weeks
before in the movie then a big plays of
backup high school quarterback named MOX
who's hiked his way to the starting
squad after an injury takes out the
team's original staff somehow difficult
some long-held dream his dad has four
marks to become the star player but Marx
has no such ambitions and tells him as
much in the most exaggerated and
terrible accent imaginable playing
football of West Canaan may have been
the opportunity of your lap time but I
don't want your life Todd to tell
whether it's the dull delivery tone or
the lines themselves that make this such
a dud but he gets no points for that
scene green bubbling James Franco made a
jump to the blockbuster a list with Sam
Raimi spider-man trilogy but it's also a
regular go-to source for some of his
most accidentally lousy acting moments
his character spends the first sequel
desperately seeking the web slinging
vigilante who he believes killed his dad
in the first film and when he lifts the
mask to reveal Spidey's identity he
discovers his best friend Peter Parker
is his new worst enemy
can't be Franko's slack-jawed gape and
awkward footwork is only exceeded in
badness phase whispered threats about
getting payback to cause you the pain
that you've caused me the whole thing
adds up to a seem more cartoonish than
the comics it was based on rain rain go
away Andie MacDowell never quite lived
up to the promise she displayed in
movies from the late 80s and early 90s
maybe it was because of a wooden
performance in Four Weddings and a
funeral
I don't usually skulk alot but I suppose
I could skunk at Skokie were required
although the film is otherwise
moderately charming there's one scene
that tends to ruin it on every rewatch
at the end of the movie in the pouring
rains you grant delivers one of those
classic sappy it was you all along
speeches to Miguel but his monologue is
interrupted by one very pointless
observation if it's still raining I
hadn't noticed there's so little emotion
in the moment from Miguel that it's
almost as if she were the funeral
featured in the film's title thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Applause]